hey what is up guys i'm kbhd here and
this is the nokia lumia 1520 all right
so i've done a few windows phone reviews
over the course of this year my most
recent being the lumia 1020 and this one
here is my favorite you guys know i like
pixels and yes that does have something
to do with it but basically because the
software is so similar to the lumia 1020
and the 920 and 925 and most of the
others i'm going to focus here on the
new hardware because this is the best
windows phone hardware yet now right off
the bat yes it's bigger than other
windows phones and that might put some
people off because these phones weren't
exactly small to begin with but you get
an exceptionally well built phone here
as you'd expect with the lumia it's the
1520 and the back has this matte white
coating it's a little bit thicker and a
little bit heavier than some other
phones but you get this unibody
enclosure and this entire phone
basically has no seams not even in the
corners so your grip is never
interrupted no matter how you hold this
phone and this phone feels really great
in the hand again it helps to have
bigger hands if you're going to hold a
bigger phone like this in one hand but
essentially it's it's a great feeling
phone you can also get this phone in a
couple of other colors like red or
yellow or black i believe and maybe blue
but i'm liking this stormtrooper look
now this phone has specs that put it on
top of just about everything and
anything released this year android ios
windows phone anything first of all it's
the first 1080p windows phone that's a
big part of why i picked it up to check
it out in the first place it's rocking a
six-inch 1080p display which puts it at
about 370 pixels per inch very sharp and
it looks much better than the display on
the lumia 1020. if you remember my
review of that beast in yellow it
actually had a 720p display and i could
see some pixels in some ui elements that
were only supposed to be one pixel wide
well the higher pixel density here on
the 1520 basically eliminates that
problem and everything looks great on it
along with the of course awesome viewing
angles great colors everything so the
display on the lumia 1520 is killer now
along with being the first windows phone
to have a 1080p display this is not the
only place where it's the king of specs
check it out this has the 2.2 gigahertz
quad-core snapdragon 800 the adreno 330
gpu which is brand new the two gigabytes
of ram gorilla glass lte it has a 20
megapixel camera with zeiss glass and a
xenon flash and basically every single
bell or whistle possible this phone is
basically fully loaded so with great
specs comes great performance throughout
launching apps and multitasking
everything you would expect and with the
larger 1080p display in windows phone
comes
more tiles which is actually really
important like a lot more tiles this is
actually nice for windows phone so
because these live tiles actually give
you a lot of glanceable information
they're kind of like widgets in a way
the way they work on android you have so
many more pixels to play with in windows
phone that you can basically get all
your live tiles in one big glanceable
sort of billboard style and get all your
information at once without even having
to scroll so that's a big thing you just
flat out cannot do on any other windows
phone because you don't have this
1920x1080 big gorgeous 6 inch display so
you do have the trade-off of the phone
itself being a little bit bigger but you
have just such a nice comfortable layout
now with all the space to work with and
the last benefit you get from all these
awesome specs and hardware is
performance of course just ridiculously
good performance so first of all let me
just say that internet explorer on
windows phone is actually pretty good
like it may not have as many features as
something like chrome on android or
safari on ios but it's extremely fast
here and i was not bothered at all by
using it i didn't feel the need to scout
out any different web browser from the
app store because page loading was
plenty fast and frame rates kept up with
me zooming in and out was extremely
smooth basically kept up with everything
i did and that's what i look for in a
mobile web browser so internet explorer
he was very good and performance was
also great in games one area i found a
lot more functional in windows phone was
the game section i guess now that i have
an xbox so it's easy it's really easy to
enjoy a game on a six inch 1080p display
when you have the newest snapdragon 800
and adreno 330 gpu powering your gaming
experience you really can't go wrong
here so the only thing you might find is
that you may wish there were more great
graphically intensive games in the
windows phone marketplace i feel like if
there was anything in the windows phone
store to challenge this phone or push it
to its limits i couldn't find it
which i guess is more of a compliment to
the phone than a complaint but yeah the
app store is growing every time i come
back to it and try windows phone so
that's a good sign but there is another
thing where performance is great is in
gaming and then another place where
performance is great i can't really talk
about this phone without talking about
the camera so obviously the lumia 1020 i
reviewed earlier had a great camera 41
megapixels but this camera experience on
the 1520 i think is every bit as good
you might not have the same resolution
but you still have 20 megapixels um a
xenon flash carl zeiss glass and the
same awesome nokia pro cam app that the
lumia 1020 had so all of this means
extremely high quality photos and a lot
of control over taking them
in all kinds of light and all types of
situations always great colors and high
detail and you can still crop down the
20 megapixel shots to zoom in on
something afterwards it might not be 40
megapixels but hell 20 is still a lot of
pixels
and rarely
you think about it not that many phones
have 20 megapixel cameras either uh
today so that's pretty impressive so
yeah this is nearly flawless hardware
objectively speaking everything about
this phone was high quality to me it
even gets a lot of the little things
right the speaker quality is really good
the earpiece quality on your calls is
really good the battery life with the
massive 3400 milliamp hour battery is
really really good the video quality
from the camera your 1080p video with
optical image stabilization is really
good the button layout for the phone on
the most part i mean it's a big phone
but i think it's laid out appropriately
for being a big phone so that was really
good so again and it also happens to
have this incredible beautiful fit and
finish that you expect from the nokia
lumia build quality uh the only thing
that might be a problem with this phone
is with the future of windows phone
getting updates since apparently the
next version of windows phone is
supposed to move to on-screen buttons
but we don't even really know this for
sure so i think it's pretty safe to say
that the lumia 1520 has provided the
best windows phone experience to date
and i love it so that's basically it
there's been your full review this is
one of my favorite phones of the year
and i'm glad i'm glad to say it's a
windows phone because i really love the
diversity of the breadth of my favorite
phones of 2013 and of course there's
much more about that coming up soon and
it's the holiday season so there's many
more videos upcoming if you want to see
those be sure to subscribe and of course
that's right next to your thumbs up
button below thank you for watching this
video and i will talk to you guys in the
next one peace
you